there's this restaurant in la called
dominico's
it's italian food from staten island i'm
familiar with it dude dominico's it's
the best
food the great tim dillon brought it
over to my house the great tim dillon
came to my house two days ago
brought over dominico's at 1pm said
just let this thaw out i'm going to come
back at 6 p.m we're going to have a fee
oh he brought over like what a friend
brought over like 800
worth of food then just just you and him
me feasting
me him and my girl and my kids and my
family was like it was like with the
whole family
on tim dillon tim paid for it he's the
best then just doesn't come back
that night so then i just have all this
food and then he's like oh i'm gonna
come he said he's gonna come yesterday
because he left his wallet at my house
so i was like okay come get your wallet
and we'll eat some food wallet with id
credit card everything never hear from
him nothing text him this morning i'm
like you're going to come he's like i'm
out of here buddy back to texas
enjoyed the miracles i'm like what about
your wallet he's like i'll get a new one
without your idea she doesn't care what
a wild man
yeah but i ate last night i ate i ate um
um
spinach bucatini pumpkin ravioli
mushroom ravioli chicken cacciatore
like 10 pounds of sauce then oh my gosh
[ __ ] in his pants yeah then me and my
family wanted to walk it off and we
walked it off all the way to salt and
straw ice cream
where i got salted cookie dough malt ice
cream but i get
yes and now and i woke up today and i'm
v jiggly
you're a little jiggly i am i got tits
today
[Music]